est-ce que comme moi tu as déjà acheté
des prodes pour augmenter tes résultats
à la salle ou de la vitamine C pour
booster ton système immunitaire si c'est
le cas désolé de te l'annoncer qu'une
étude a analysé les compléments
alimentaires vendus sur Amazon et a
conclu que la moitié mente sur les
effets voire contiennent des ingrédients
cachés inutile ou carrément interdit
abrant quand on sait qu'un quart des
Français consomment ces produits tous
les ans bien souvent sans trop savoir à
quoi ça sert exactement un marché
douteux qui génère plus de 2 milliards
par an alors dans cet océan de poudre de
perlin Papin et de pilule miracle
servonsnous de la science pour trouver
les compléments alimentaires qui ont une
vraie utilité et ceux que vous devez
éviter ces vitamine vous empoisonne tu
as sûrement déjà pris de la vitamine D
tu sais ce sont ces ampoules que les
médecins prescrivent souvent en hiver
normal la vitamine D est une substance
assez rare dans l'alimentation on la
synthétise surtout en s'exposant au
soleil sauf que les capsules sur
l'ordonnance du médecin sont ultra
concentré jusqu'à 80 fois la dose
journalière prenez ce genre de dose tous
les jours et vous risquez une
hypercalcémie votre corps va absorber
trop de calcium h donc faiblesse
musculaire trouble neuropsychiatrique
déshydratation calcul Réau tout ça sans
forcément de symptômes apparents sans le
savoir les gens s'empoisonnent
quotidiennement à cause d'un excès de
vitamine d'un autre côté une carence en
vitamine D ça fait mal fragilité
immunitaire osseuse cardiaque 25 % de
risque en plus d'une mort prématurée
alors les gens en achètent eux même et
en abusent c'est un vrai problème
d'actualité alors qu'il ne suffit de pas
grandchose pour avoir sa dose normale de
vitamine D 30 minutes au soleil deux
fois par semaine suffiseent pourtant on
que 70 % des Français n'ont pas leur
dose journalière et qu'un peu plus de 6
% sont en carence sinon tu peux toujours
tester le remède de grand-mère une demi
cuillère à café d'huile de fois de Moru
par jour pas plus les vitamines ne sont
pas toujours vos amis en fait ton corps
se régule très bien lui-même et à part
cette vitamine D il est extrêmement rare
d'être en carence car les vitamines on
ne les trouve pas que dans les fruits il
y en a dans tout ce qui est vivant
viande légumes œuf une vitamine c'est
juste une molécule qu'on n pas capable
de synthétiser donc ce qui est une
vitamine pour nous ne l'est pas
forcément pour les autres espèces par
exemple pour la vitamine C ou l'acide
lascorbique Si tu veux te la péter la
plupart des mammifères arrivent à la
produire eux-même alors que nous les
singes et les cochons d'indes on a perdu
la capacité la loose une théorie suggère
que ça pourrait être la faute d'un
rétrovirus qui s'est répandu dans notre
gonome et a désactivé cette aptitude
mais l'explication la plus probable
c'est plutôt qu'on avait un régime
abondant en fruits à l'époque donc un
apport extérieur suffisant en vitamine C
le fait de pouvoir en produire est donc
devenu inutile et a disparu ant la
vitamine C est cruciale dans notre vie
elle permet d'absorber le fer
synthétiser le collagène cicatriser les
tissus et même ralentir le
vieillissement car c'est un bon
antioxydant au global et attention si
vous êtes humeur vous absorbez deux fois
moins bien la vitamine C et croyez-moi
vous ne voulez pas être en carence les
marins connaissent bien la terrible
maladie qui te frappe quand tu n'as plus
assez de vitamines ce qui arrive souvent
sur les bateaux à cause d'un manque trop
long de fruits et légumes ils appellent
ça la peste des mers le score but le
collagène devient instable votre peau
tombe en lambau vos dents aussi c'est
l'hémorragie puis la mort mais ce n'est
pas une raison pour vous précipiter sur
vos gellules de vitamine C car si vous
en abuser sur le long terme vous allez
vous taper des diarrées de l'enfer voire
des accidents cardiaques heureusement
ton corps limite la capacité maximale
qu'il peut absorber donc à moins de
t'injecter la vitamine C directement ces
pellules ne peuvent pas être létales
alors comment être certain de rester
dans les bonnes doses il suffit tout
simplement de manger régulièrement des
fruits et légumes c'est même le meilleur
moyen de choper au passage d'autres
vitamines super utiles prenons la
carotte par exemple c'est l'un des
aliments les plus riches en vitamine A
alors non ça ne vous rendra pas plus
aimable par contre elle stimule votre
production de gloubu rouge et le
développement de certains organes dont
vos yeux un déficit peut donc carrément
vous rendre aveugle ou vulnérable à
certaines maladies et infections et
chaque année ça tue des milliers
d'enfants dans les pays défavorisés vous
avez peut-être déjà vu des influenceurs
qui vous disaient d'en prendre pour
diminuer votre acné c'est pas faux sauf
que pour commencer à avoir un effet
positif il faut en prendre des doses
très élevées le problème c'est que sur
les longues périodes ça peut devenir
toxique que quand tu abuses de la
vitamine A elle peut augmenter la
pression de ton liquide céphalorachidien
qui entoure ton cerveau jusqu'à
t'envoyer direct dans le coma et
l'overdose arrive bien plus vite qu'on
le pense avec des aliments riches en
vitamine A pas besoin de pilule une
soixantaine de patates douces ou 1,2 kg
de fois de bœuf dans la journée devrait
vous mettre au tapis alors peut-on
tomber dans le Comat en mangeant trop de
carottes pas de panique avant que ça
arrive tu vas vite t'apercevoir qu'un
truc n'est pas normal ta peau va
littéralement dir orange c'est la
caroténodermie et oui quand on abuse des
vitamines ça peut rapidement virer au
cauchemar pire pour la plupart d'entre
elles et même pour un usage normal vous
trouverez autant de papi qui prouvent
leur efficacité et que d'études qui
expliquent que ça n'a aucun impact
bénéfique c'est en partie dû à un biaet
difficile à éviter souvent les gens qui
ont des carences ont aussi une mauvaise
hygiène de vie accentuant ainsi les
résultats négatifs quand tu achètes des
vitamin sur Internet on te propose
généralement aussi des oligoéléments et
des sels minéraux calcium magnésium
potassium fer et cetera ce sont aussi
des molécules dont ton corps a besoin en
petite quantité l'excès est généralement
éliminé par vos reins mais une dose
mortelle est possible 5 g de magnésium
par jour a déjà tué des gens enfin la
dernière superstar des vitamines sur
Amazon c'est la vitamine F vous n'en
avez jamais entendu parler c'est
l'ancien nom des oméga3 oméga6 elles
sont indispensables pour votre corps et
agissent positivement sur plein
d'aspects mais surtout elles pourrait
ralentir le vieillissement du cerveau
plusieurs études ont même montré un lien
entre la consommation d'oméga3 pendant
la grossesse et une meilleure motricité
visuelle ou maîtrise du langage chez les
enfants ainsi qu'une réduction des
maladies cognitives avec l'âge c'est
surtout les oméga3 qu'on a du mal à
trouver dans notre alimentation moderne
mais là encore pas besoin de compléments
chimiques pour faire le plein viser les
sardines ou plus modérément les macros
le saumon ou encore les graines de lin
globalement si vous pensez en carence
faites comme moi vérifiez-le avec une
prise de sang et une consultation chez
le médecin surtout que certaines
molécules peuvent interagir avec les
médicaments par exemple on suspecte que
les vitamines C pourraient avoir des
conséquences néfastes lors d'une
chimiothérapie raison de plus pour ne
pas te précipiter sur Amazon aujourd'hui
facile de tomber sur des compléments
inefficaces ou pire dangereux c'est
crucial d'avoir une source fiable comme
notre partenaire nutripur parce qu'ils
prennent au sérieux ce que naturel et
efficace signifie pas d'additifs
inutiles ou nocif des protéines aux
vitamines chaque produit est conçu avec
un souci de qualité et de transparence
vous pourrez voir la liste complète de
tous les ingrédients ainsi que leur
provenance une entreprise de Toulouse
leader sur le marché et qui suit des
athlètes de haut niveau regardez par
exemple leur hachwaganda ou leur
collagène pas de poudre de perlin Papin
une combinaison de bon produit efficace
le plus beau dans tout ça il y a toute
une gamme selon vos besoins que vous
souhaitez prendre du muscle perdre du
poids être en bonne santé réduire votre
stress vous allez trouver votre bonheur
et si vous ne savez pas trop quoi
prendre pas de panique vous pouvez
prendre rendez-vous avec leur
nutritionniste pour vous aider à faire
le meilleur choix selon votre projet
tout ça avec un très bon rapport
qualité-prix alors si vous êtes comme
moi soucieux de ce que vous mettez dans
votre corps et désireux d'optimiser
votre santé et vos performances de
manière sûre et efficace faites un tour
sur nutriure le lien est juste en
dessous de la description les
compléments alimentaires peuvent-ils
vous rendre plus fort quand vous
commencez la muscu on vous conseille des
dizaines de compléments si vous avez pas
votre gros peau de poudre vous ne
progresserez jamais mais est-ce que
c'est vrai commençons par les protéines
en poudre la fameuse way pour grossir
ses muscles il faut que vos cellules
prennent du volume un muscle c'est comme
des poupé russes un assemblage
d'éléments emboîés les uns dans les
autres eux-mêmes composés de ces tuyau
de fibres qu'on appelle des myofiries et
ça c'est juste une grosse chaîne de
plusieurs protéines différentes quand
vous faites des efforts vos muscles ont
la capacité d'emmagasiner plus de
protéines puis d'en relâcher après
l'effort pour se muscler il faut que la
quantité de protéines stocké par vos
muscles soit plus élevé que celle qu' le
relâche mais aussi avoir un entraînement
approprié un bon apport en protéin une
bonne récupe du repos et un bilan
calorique satisfaisant on appelle ça
l'hypertropie musculaire donc évidemment
plus vous avez de protéines à
disposition pour vos muscles plus ils
peuvent en consommer attention quand
même toutes les protéines ne se valent
pas les plus intéressantes sont celles
compos d'acid aminé essentiel ce que le
corps ne synthétise pas naturellement ou
trop lentement donc on se jette pas sur
le PO de pote alors non le surplu va se
transformé en graisse quelle quantité
alors la science à tranché au-delà de
1,6 g par kilo et par jour il n'y a plus
aucun effet bénéfique vous faites 80 kg
il vous faut alors 128 g de protéines
par jour soit plus de 5 steaks hachés
quand même et on sait aujourd'hui
qu'abuser de la viande rouge augmente
les risques de crise cardiaque ou de
cancer 22 œuf alors combien bon alors
4re do de way on comprend vite que c'est
là que les compléments prennent toute
leur valeur beaucoup plus facile à
ingurgiter effet secondaires sympa les
protéines sont un vrai coupe fin fini le
grignotage en plus de votre po de way on
vous conseille de la créatine pour vous
doperer votre corps en produit
naturellement elle ne fera pas grossir
vos muscles mais va aider à synthétiser
l'ATP le carburant principal de vos
muscles le but est de saturer
l'organisme de créatine environ 10 fois
la quantité naturelle cette méga réserve
d'énergie va améliorer vos performances
dans des activités de haute intensité et
de courte durée on parle d'une
augmentation de 1 à 15 % de vos
performances la créatine pourrait en
revanche de manière marginale accélérer
vos pertes de cheveux si vous étiez
prédisposé en boostant un dérivé de la
testostérone les compléments qui
contiennent des acides aminés pourront
vous apporter un petit plus c'est de la
chimie fine de haut niveau pour
maximiser vos entraînements par contre
tout ce qui est à base de taorine c'est
du marketing à part votre chat qui
deviendrait aveugle si n'en avait pas
dans ses croquettes les effets sont
négligeables sur vos capacités physiques
et si on regardait du côté des plans une
qui a la côte en ce moment c'est la
chwag Gonda disé depuis des centaines
d'années en médecine traditionnelle
indienne elle diminue le taux de
cortisol et augmente légèrement la
testostérone nickel pour la muscu par
contre attention surdosage somnolante
diarrhée vomissement lésion du foie et
elle est très dangereuse associée à des
médicaments assez communs c'est pour ça
que les stéroïdes sont interdits en
compétition même si on prend pas en
compte l'aspect fairplay c'est en
premier pour protéger la santé des
pratiquants ça ne vaut pas le coup de
risquer sa vie pour des performances les
plus connus sont les stéroïdes
anabolisants qui copient les effets de
la testostérone ils vont booster la
syèse des protéines et du coup votre
masse musculaire les effets secondaires
sont sans faim acné ravageuse problème
de fertilité de libido trouble
psychologique lésion du foie du cœur
addiction perte de cheveux poussé de
poil ce n'est pas pour rien que le taux
de mortalité chez les bodybuilders en
activité est plus élevé que le reste de
la population ces substances ont
tellement d'effet qu'on s'en sert même
en tant que traitement thérapeutique
aider des malades à conserver leur masse
musculaire ou stimuler la croissance
mais seulement à tout petite dose les
compléments alimentaires peuvent-ils
vous soigner quand j'étais petit ma mère
adoré me filer de la gelée royale en
hiver mais maintenant que j'ai la
capacité de m'informer moi-même je peux
enfin dire que ah mais c'est grave bien
la gelée en fait on en a donné à des
souris des mouches à fruits des criquets
et des vers à soie à chaque fois leur
longévité a augmenté chez les souris
c'était jusqu'à 25 % avec une réduction
des effets négatifs liés à l'âge et ça
c'est sans parler de l'effet sur les
abeilles ellees-mêmes on en parlait dans
cette vidéo on a peu de recherche sur
l'homme mais elle contient plein de bons
éléments protéines acides aminés acides
gras la nature est super bien faite
l'aspirine existe depuis 1897 mais elle
est inspirée de la salicine contenue
dans l'écorse de sa on s'en sert depuis
des millénaires pour soulager douleur et
inflammation les échinacés sont un bon
remède de grand-mère pour éviter les
rhumes elles sont surchargées en
principe actif et antioxydant comme par
exemple des polysaccharides connu pour
activer les réponses immunitaire pour
améliorer votre humeurs pendant le
blouse de l'hiver il y a l'orpine rose
qui pousse dans les régions froides ou
montagneuses on l'utilise en médecine
traditionnelle depuis plusieurs
centaines d'années en Russie et dans les
pays scandinaves et les études semblent
confirmer des vertus antistress et le
mil Pertuis foré est concentré en
hyperphorine une substance qui agit
exactement comme un antidépresseur sur
la recapture de la sérotonine sans
parler de la théine ou de la caféine
quasi même substance dans deux plantes
différentes elle traversent les
murailles du cerveau un peu à la manière
des drogues psychoactives pour augmenter
votre vigilance et vous protéger contre
certaines maladies neurodégénératives
attention disclaimer toutes ces
substances sont des aides et non des
médicaments mais les effets sont
adéiables voire terrifiant comme pour
Steve bchler jeune joueur de baseball de
23 ans il fait un malaise en plein match
le médecin est appelé il pense à un
simple coup de chaleur évacué du terrain
il mourra peu après le médecin accusera
l'ephédrine un complément alimentaire
aujourd'hui interdit les substances ont
beau être naturel et reste chimique le
corps produit presque tout ce dont on a
besoin même les bactéries vous en avez
peut-être même déjà pris après une
gastro ce sont les probiotiqu notre
corps est composé à 50 % de bactéries
c'est pas sale on en a besoin dans nos
intestins pour digérer ce qu' l'on mange
sur notre peau pour pas laisser passer
les mauvaises bactéries dans notre tube
digestif pour stimuler notre système
immunitaire on sait même aujourd'hui que
ça certaines maladies ont en commun un
cocktail de bactéries spécifique comme
pour la schizophrénie par exemple on
arrive même à soigner certaines maladies
grâce à la transplantation fécale on
prend les bactéries du caca d'une
personne pas malade et on les implante
dans les intestins d'une personne malade
paragouttant mais les premiers résultats
sont épousouflants à quand nos géues de
bactéries stoppp dépression ou perte de
poids pour bientôt d'après la science
les compléments sont là pour optimiser
le fonctionnement normal de notre
organisme pas pour nous transformer en
super-héros ni guérir le cancer comme
tout dans la vie c'est une question
d'équilibre maintenant que vous en savez
plus vous allez pouvoir choisir vos
compléments autrement qu'avec des idées
reçues si vous arrivez à identifier vos
besoins ça peut vraiment vous changer la
vie alors pas de raison de s'en
priver